season two of Star Trek discovery began
streaming yesterday on CBS all access
and to celebrate the cast at the red
carpet in New York including a new
addition to the universe that we like to
call hot spot
Hobbs pocket so let's all think about
that for a moment Spock is that a smile
I see on your face yes so who is the new
hot spot he's Ethan Peck 32 years old
and starred on the series 10 Things I
Hate About You
he's also the grandson of Oscar winner
Gregory Peck
did he ever give you any pieces of
advice when you were like hey I want to
follow in your footsteps I know we never
really did talk about that unfortunately
I wish we had the gift of that is that
I've had to like look deeply and
scrounge for my own answers of things
this is awkward but I'm here at
Starfleet's order to take command of the
Discovery spot comes aboard discovery
after answering a distress call from the
enterprise yes that enterprise Anson
mountain joins the cast is Captain Pike
from the original Star Trek pilot he's a
super fan I've seen every episode of
original at least three times you need
to trust us sir I told you we don't
abandon each other I will tell you
something season one it was a sweeping
introduction now the war is over and we
have a moment to slow down and to take a
breath also new for season two Rebecca
romaine joins the cast as a brunette
number one there's an added pressure to
not let anyone down
the fans are like always in the back of
my head I'm like gotta get this right
you know wherever our mission takes us
I'm trying to make a little noise
[Music]